What gives, Mickey?
Disney+ subscribers awoke on New Year's Day
to find that the brand new streaming service
had removed several movies from its library.
Needless to say, these subscribers were less
than pleased.
The deletions are surprising for a couple
of reasons.
First, everything on Disney+ is owned by the
Walt Disney Corporation.
With none of its content licensed from other
parties, there doesn't appear to be any reason
for anything to ever disappear from the streamer's
library.
In fact, many subscribers were under the impression
that the Disney+ library would not be rotating
out titles for any reason.
For another, the fact that content has begun
to disappear so soon after the streamer's
November 14 launch is surprising.
While the list of the vanished titles isn't
very extensive, the Disney+ library wasn't
super-deep to begin with, and the deletions
appear to have taken place for no good reason.
Perhaps the most glaring omission from the
Disney+ library is the 1990 classic Home Alone,
which a truckload of subscribers are likely
to have watched mere days before it vanished.
It is, after all, a Christmas classic.
We suppose it stands to reason that it may
only appear on the streamer seasonally.
If that’s the case, however, Disney should
have informed its subscribers that some titles
would only be available at certain times of
the year.
The flick's 1992 sequel also disappeared,
although 1997's Home Alone 3, which features
an entirely different cast and is nowhere
near as well-regarded as the first two, is
still available.
In addition to those films, the offerings
that have mysteriously left the service are:
Dr. Dolittle, Flicka, Pirates of the Caribbean:
On Stranger Tides, Strange Magic, The Wonderful
World of Disney: Magical Holiday Celebration,
White Wilderness, Mickey, Donald, Goofy: The
Three Musketeers, Garfield 2: A Tail of Two
Kitties, the 2006 remake of The Shaggy Dog,
and The Sandlot.
To make matters worse, Disney has had no public
statement to offer about the situation as
of this video.
The only possible clue has come from Reddit,
where a single user was reportedly told by
customer service that the deletions weren't
intentional, but were actually a technical
issue.
If it were a mere technical problem, however,
it seems like Disney would have said something
publicly about it by now.
In fact, the Mouse House's complete radio
silence isn't helping matters.
Disney+ was already looking at the loss of
a not-insignificant number of subscribers
now that the first season of its original
Star Wars series The Mandalorian has concluded.
To follow that up by deleting random titles
from its library doesn't seem like a great
way to reassure anyone that the service is
worth keeping.
You may be wondering, with all of the titles
that have suddenly departed, if Disney+ will
be adding anything new to its library this
month.
Perhaps unsurprisingly, the service will be
adding plenty of new titles.
Most significantly, last year's live-action
remakes of Aladdin and The Lion King will
be streaming on the 8th and 28th, respectively.
Already available as of January 1 are the
2003 classic Holes, the 1993 sports comedy
Cool Runnings, and the fascinating 2014 documentary
Marvel: 75 Years, From Pulp to Pop!
Also arriving at various points during the
month will be new episodes of Disney+ original
series Forky Asks a Question, Encore!, High
School Musical: The Musical: The Series, Marvel's
Hero Project, Pixar in Real Life, Disney Family
Sundays, and The World According to Jeff Goldblum.
Also, the third and final season of Marvel's
Runaways will hit the platform on January
10, and a wealth of entire seasons of Disney
Channel and NatGeo series such as The Lodge,
The Proud Family, and Dog: Impossible will
also be making their debuts.
It stands to reason, though, that subscribers
would like some reassurance that their favorite
content isn't going to suddenly disappear
from Disney+ at some point down the road.
We'll be keeping a vigilant eye out for any
statement from the House of Mouse, and we'll
update you as soon as any new information
becomes available.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.